what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can't decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so we're going to be a little bit
dangerous here we are going to we're
going to cover secret Empire now I love
love love love love so you can Empire I
think it's one of the best written
stories Marvel's had for quite some time
and I really love the way that it all
comes together because to me it tells
this incredible story about the
superheroes one of the great things
about secret Empire is it shows how
pivotal Captain America is to like the
moral focal point of all the superheroes
on earth not just the United States but
all the superheroes on earth and you got
to keep them on Captain America has led
a multitude of different groups it's
usually been the Avengers but whether
it's like a small group here and there
or whether it's like his Secret Avengers
or whether he fights alongside other
superheroes a lot of people across the
world look to Steve Rogers because of
his leadership capabilities because of
the fact that he refuses to give up he
never gives in but the whole point of
secret Empire is to give us a scenario
where he turned the entire tables of
everything that's happened on his head
now of course we have all the lead-up to
secret empire from Captain America Steve
Rogers we have part of Captain America
Sam Wilson but the comments section for
a lot of those videos just turned into
like racial you know arguments and
bigotry and so for the most part I just
stopped doing those videos so you're
welcome to catch up on those on your own
but the fact remains that with with
Steve Rogers remember his entire history
was basically modified Steve Rogers we
knew that was injected with the Super
Soldier Serum he went on to become
Captain America you know he was frozen
in ice for 20 30 years
he was eventually discovered by the
Avengers thought out and he became the
hero that we all know and love
it wasn't until all-new all-different
marvel that we suddenly had a shield
basically going through and grabbing all
these different fragments of different
cosmic cubes that existed over the years
piecing them all together creating one
cohesive Cosmic Cube that she'll decided
to create the the whole concept of
Pleasant Hill and Pleasant Hill was
basically using a Cosmic Cube to more or
less warp reality and create this sort
of idyllic prison that villains could be
kept in with no idea that they were
actually being held in this alternate
reality so to speak and so the result
was that when Captain America Steve
Rogers and the other Avengers learned
about what was going on it was a
complete violation of the civil rights
of all the different villains that
existed out there and so they basically
broke in to Pleasant Hill they
essentially brought the whole thing down
you know at the same time there was a
big breakout that was initiated and it
ultimately resulted
and everything shield had done coming to
light by way of rick jones of course one
of the friends of the original
incredible whole crew standard we
basically hacked everything tip the
avengers off dump the information out to
the world and it resulted in shield
really kind of getting a negative
reputation or even worse or reputation
that it had before but it brought the
evidence of pleasant hill delight and it
allowed the avengers to bring it down
but in the middle of all that we ended
up finding out this cosmic cube had
become sentient and it's always been
that way you know the cosmic ears always
become sentient and marvel comics in
some form or fashion they end up
becoming being just because of the fact
that they're just pure energy that will
eventually take on an actual form the
shaper of worlds is a cosmic cube cubic
the original cosmic you but this one was
basically composed of different
fragments over the years and because of
the fact that the red skull had created
and used his own cosmic cubes somewhere
along line this cube itself when it
became sentient because it was new it
was basically a child and as a child it
recognized that one of its fragments had
been used by the red skull somewhere
along the line and so it began to look
at the red skull as somewhat of a father
figure and in turn the red skull began
to corrupt the sentient Cosmic Cube and
used it to not only restore the youth of
Captain America Steve Rogers but to also
modify his entire history to make him a
Hydra agent and so because of this but
Steve Rogers that exists now an all-new
all-different marvel is a hydration
that's really how all that came to be
now for us again we go more in depth
into that as we go through our Captain
America Steve Rogers stories but a
secret Empire number zero he basically
made his first strike and everything had
been leading up to that point when he
took out when he killed the Red Skull
when he recruited Baron Zemo to his
cause the whole idea was to bring
everything crashing down not a problem
that writer Nick Spencer ran into was
the idea of the Cosmic Cube itself if
the Cosmic Cube it going by the name
comic is the reason why Captain America
is a Hydra agent that all somebody has
to do is capture her and try to force
her or at least brainwash her into
sending things back to rights and so
what he ended up doing was basically
having the Cosmic Cube more or less
reformed and then eventually just broke
it into a thousand shards broken into
pieces all over the place by the Hydra
scientist Erik Selvig who of course
basically turned coded against Captain
America now of course again the reason
for this was because of the fact that
Erik so they could basically grown close
to Copic as a little girl kind of
viewing her as a surrogate daughter of
sources so the result is that where
Captain America wanted to keep her
prisoner if not just so
remove her away from everything it
resulted in Celtic just kind of
dispersing her all across the Marvel
Universe that she could be reformed at
some point along the line and her
sentience would be restored so instead
of just allowing her to be a prisoner
she was kind of killed so to speak
that's basically what happened to her
character and so what this story does is
it sets the stage for tracking down all
the pieces of the cosmic cube or at
least that's really what issue number
one will do what this immediate segment
of the story does is show us how the
hero's failed now again when Captain
America launching his first strike this
came in a couple forms remember Carol
Danvers as Captain Marvel had been
working on a shield that was designed
for the purpose of basically protecting
the earth from exterior threats Steve
Rogers after becoming director of shield
fired Carol Danvers and then kept the
shield project and then turned around
and basically initiated this global
shield to keep Carol Danvers and all
these guys out and the reason why was
because of the fact that remember
Captain America Steve Rogers had taken
the queen of each Atari race which
exists very similar to termites or ants
and the idea was that they would
constantly keep coming to try to locate
their queen by keeping the Queen hidden
on the planet Earth it essentially
created infinite waves up to tari forces
that would continue to wear down the
superheroes that were fighting outside
of Earth and trying to keep the wave
from penetrating the earth before the
shield went up the issue was that after
having Carol Danvers and all those super
powerful beings outside earth captain
america immediately initiated a shield
which kept them out they couldn't get in
and all they were dealing is just
running into wave after wave after wave
up Tatari forces trying to arrive on
earth itself now that begs the question
why don't they just leave like why don't
they just go anywhere else in truth a
lot of that's just for the sake of
storytelling just for the sake of
showing us what it is they're doing but
you know for whatever reason they don't
if for no other reason than to just kind
of keep the story going but back on
earth proper with the forces of Hydra
basically launching their attack across
the United States specifically in New
York and the capital by taking over the
lighthouse this basically brings in all
the superheroes now on the whole this is
basically superheroes versus
supervillains that's really what it is I
mean it was initially it was Hydra going
to all these villains and saying look we
know what shield did to you guys yes you
know I'm technically the director of
shield but we will make a better life
for you we will make a better world all
you have to do is fight on our behalf
and this was designed to be a ruse and a
distraction and the reason why is
because you remember when it comes to
the Earth's Mightiest Heroes like
to be Avengers being an Earth's
Mightiest hero doesn't necessarily mean
the most powerful it means being the
Earth's Mightiest hero in terms of your
willingness to keep going what you stand
for and your moral compass head so the
Avengers would just keep on fighting
time and time again and they wouldn't
really worry about the idea of how
powerful they were they would just try
to hold everything a check but even then
there were still some pretty powerful
beings here the new Red Hulk is here
visions Scarlet Witch Miles Morales
spider-man but holographic Tony Stark
riri Williams the new Iron Man you know
I guess going by the name Iron Heart
Hercules Quicksilver you know the
champions The Avengers the whole nine
yards it's everybody doing the best they
can to stop the forces of Hydra and the
cool thing about this is we get this
really interesting narrative along the
way and it actually comes from Black
Widow which I really feel like Black
Widow is giving some of the best
treatment and storytelling in this story
that she has in quite some time or at
least for the first half of the story
anyway but the fact remains Black Widow
really kind of addresses all this and
saying that you know as a person without
any powers but four digits training in
conflict and has consistently been part
of like shield and the Avengers and the
superhero community overall one of the
issues that the superhero community ran
into was that much like you know the
human body growing a resistance to
various illnesses or various cures the
superhero community began to basically
develop an immunity or resistance to the
idea that they could lose that they had
constantly won against like overwhelming
odds
you know the scrolls would invade the
planet Earth and the superheroes would
win some villain would try to take over
the entirety of the world or the United
States and the superheroes would win
they always came out on top that
eventually a time came when they never
thought that they could lose and they
could do no wrong and that's the cool
thing about this is because it's not
like the heroes are full of hubris right
it's all I did it's not Casey at the bat
well they throw one ball you know in
case he's just kind of sitting there
read a newspaper and they throw another
ball and Casey's goofing around then
they throw the third ball and Casey
strikes out I mean it's not them just
kind of being arrogant or anything along
those lines
it's just the idea that there's this
aspect of their personality or do they
fought so many different villains they
just couldn't really consider themselves
to be people who would lose and that
would make sense they just think about
it over the course of Marvel Comics
publication history even before the
events of all-new all-different marvel
the first civil war yeah the super
heroes lost but Captain America died he
created a rallying point and then we got
the events of Dark Reign one of the
darkest eras in the history of the
Marvel Universe when Norman Osborn took
over director of shield the super
heroes came out on top when they exposed
Norman on one of the guy that he was
this Scrolls invaded the planet Earth
during the events of secret Empire
creating all these doppelgangers of
superheroes and they came out on top
Bannos wielded the Infinity Gauntlet the
heroes came out on top all these stories
all these events that took place the
heroes always ended up winning yes there
were casualties but they always want and
is this idea of Nick Spencer sort of
turning that on its head and saying but
what would happen if they didn't what
would happen if the heroes didn't win
now the question is how because Captain
America by himself is incapable of
defeating all these different
superheroes he just doesn't have the
power to do so and so what he did is he
turned the heroes against each other and
this is designed to feed off the fallout
from civil war - because remember Civil
War - was Carol Danvers you know Captain
Marvel going against Tony Stark but it
fragmented the entirety of the superhero
community because he was basically
violating people's right to his
pre-crime it was well they haven't
committed a crime yet but they will
so let's arrest them before they do and
so what ended up happening here is that
people began taking up sides they began
saying no no no I'm with Ironman or I am
with Carol Danvers whatever the case may
be but because of the fact that this
happened so soon after the events of
Civil War - there was no time for people
to band together there was no time for
them to basically begin making amends
for their own actions put the past in
the past and start moving forward this
was an immediate response with the Hydra
inner circle Captain America Baron Zemo
Arnim Zola hives Kraken and Madame Hydra
all basically showing up on the scene
the fact that Captain America is a Hydra
agent is a crushing blow to the
superheroes because they now have to
face the fact that the greatest hero
among them is the one that's been
working against them and that's the
craziest thing about this because
remember following the revelation or
probably be altering a reality by the
Cosmic Cube and Captain America's past
making him a Hydra agent every single
thing that he did whether it was a story
in Marvel Comics that was removed from
the ongoing events and saw Captain
America shaking hand of old man Logan or
whether it was something to tie directly
into Captain America's own stories he
was always operating at the background
he was always working against the
superheroes of the Marvel Universe
and so we always had to keep this in
mind everything was moving towards the
idea of him taking over the country and
that's why civil war tea was such a
great story from the perspective of
Captain America because with Captain
America being thrown into the mix what
basically revealed was that he was the
1d initiated the entire series of events
he's the one that set up a conflict
between Carol Danvers and iron man he's
the one that goaded them into fighting
one another he's the reason why the
entirety of civil war two happened in a
lot of different ways and why the
superhero community remained split and
so with them facing the fact the Captain
America is the one against them what we
end up having are these series of events
that aren't fully explained they
probably will be you know as a story
goes on but at the moment one of the
first things that happens is Jane Foster
Thor's taken out because remember there
was one of the most powerful characters
in the Marvel Universe with her near
invulnerability with her hammer her
super strength she's somebody who could
easily just become a one-woman wrecking
crew with regards to like the forces of
hydrogen start tearing things apart and
so what isn't happening throughout this
entire monologue Black Widow continues
to say things like we thought because we
were right but we fell because we were
wrong and so what isn't happening is
Jane fosters effectively made intangible
by vision who's corrected by the forces
of Hydra The Scarlet Witch has
effectively taken over although we don't
really know how it is that happened and
then ultimately Captain America is able
to reach down and pick up the hammer of
Thor and that was one of the biggest
moments in the entirety of this story
and the reason why is because of the
fact that people look at it and they
immediately freak they were like no no
it says only people who are worthy can
lift a hammer for Calculon Captain
America pick it up well they admitted
how it was a Captain America we pick it
up the hammer enchantment does not say
whosoever holds this hammer if he be a
good guy shall possess the power for it
says whosoever holds this hammer if he
be worthy shall possess the power of
Thor and we know by virtue of the story
with Odin's son the reason why he can't
lift his own hammers because he doesn't
believe that he's worthy Odin's son is
worthy to pick up his hammer he just
doesn't believe he is and so with Jane
Foster effectively added the equation
Captain America wrecks everybody in a
superhero community what's left of the
Avengers the whole nine yards and leaves
them without any real moral compass at
this point they're just a broken group
and we'll find out how broken they are
in secret Empire number one but with
that being said guys we're gonna go
ahead and bring this video to an end if
you are new here to come as explained
make sure you guys are the sub but to
become part of the rock Court you guys
enjoy this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you guys later
please
[Music]
you